بدأت بطولة evion في الأصل
Evian Masters كحدث في
الجولة الأوروبية للسيدات عام 1994.
بدأنا ببطولة صغيرة جدًا
لأن لدينا هنا
سيدة كمديرة عامة وقد أوضحت لي
ولوالدي أنه يتعين علينا القيام بذلك
بطولة للسيدات والفتيات، وبدأنا
بهذه الطريقة وكانت هذه هي الخطوة الأولى مع
جائزة مالية صغيرة جدًا تبلغ مليون
بطاطا مقلية في عام 2013، وقد تم
رفع مستوى الحدث بعد أن أعلن مفوض جولة LPJ،
مايك وان، أن
بطولة إيفيان ستصبح الخامسة الكبرى
في بطولة السيدات.  تقويم الجولف شرحت
له
توقف عن التفكير مثل الرجال حتى لو كنت
مايك واحد إذا كان الرجل لا يقلد وفي
النهاية اتخذ هذا القرار المذهل
في منشار
استقرار الرياضة وهو إنشاء
تخصص خامس وكنا الخامس
أنا فخور جدًا
عندما بدأت قبل 30 عامًا
ببطولة محلية حيث أعتقد أن عائلتي كانت
المتفرج الوحيد حول
ملعب الجولف والآن لديك بطولة
عالمية المستوى حتى كما قلنا بالفرنسية،
آمل أن يستمر
عام 2023.  الذكرى السنوية العاشرة
لبطولة evion وخلال تلك السنوات العشر، كان
من بين الفائزين في الأحداث أمثال
ليديا كو سوزان باترسون وواحدة من
أكبر نجوم جولة LPGA والتي
حققت فوزها الرئيسي الثاني هنا منذ 12 شهرًا، مرحبًا
أنا ريك هندرسون بطولة إيفيان 2022
كان الفوز بتخصصي الثاني هدفًا كبيرًا
بالنسبة لي، ولذلك كان من الرائع حقًا أن أتمكن من القيام بذلك
العام الماضي أمام الجميع، حيث
ظهرت هندرسون على الساحة عندما كانت
مراهقة وحصلت على
لقب بطولة PGA للسيدات في عام 2016 لتصبح
ثاني أصغر امرأة تفوز بلقب البطولة.  لم يسبق لي أن فزت
بلقب كبير
منذ ذلك الفوز، تشعر الفتاة البالغة من العمر 25 عامًا أن
كرة القدم النسائية قد انتقلت من قوة إلى
قوة، أشعر أنني في كل عام
أخرج هنا في جولة في الملعب،
والموهبة تستمر في أن تصبح أقوى
وأفضل وهو أمر حقًا  مثيرة وأنت
تعلم أنه في الأحداث هناك المزيد من المعجبين
الآن والفتيات الصغيرات
وأعتقد أنه إذا تمكنا من الاستمرار في إلهام
الجيل القادم، فسيكون الاثنان في
مكان رائع لفترة طويلة حقًا حيث
يعمل والدها ديف كمدرب لها و  إن ممارسة لعبة
غولف الأخت بريتاني
هي حقًا شأن عائلي بالنسبة لهندرسون، لذا
كان والدي مدربي منذ أن كنت في الثالثة من
عمري، وأعتقد أن هذا هو الوقت الذي
بدأت فيه اللعبة وكان دائمًا
يعلمني ويساعدني على
التحسن، لذا فهو  لقد لعبت دورًا رائعًا
في لعبة الجولف الخاصة بي، كما تعلمون
أختي الكبرى التي تحمل معي الآن
في جولة وهي أكبر بست سنوات، لذلك عندما كبرت
كنت أحاول دائمًا التغلب عليها وأحاول
دائمًا مطاردتها وأن
أكون مثلها حتى الآن  إن وجودها هنا
والقدرة على مشاركة هذه الرحلة
والسفر إلى أماكن مذهلة
ومشاركتها معًا هو أمر مميز حقًا